greetings from podcastville it's monday
the 10th of august
the church what's happening now is
brought to you by draftkings listen
this saturday is ufc 252 and draftkings
has a knockout of a [ __ ] deal
better buck to win 252
what did you say better buck to win 252
put money on either fight in the main
event for the opportunity to win 252
you can't beat those odds where else
does a dollar go so far
don't be a sucker download the draftking
sports
book app new users get a sign up bonus
up to a thousand dollars
get in on the action download right now
draftkingsportsbook
now and use code church plus for a
limited time
just for the church family all new users
get a signup bonus
of a thousand dollars did you hear me a
thousand dollars you got a grand
when you get draftking sports book app
and use code
church only at draftkings sportsbook
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 older
new jersey indiana and pennsylvania only
deposit bonus
requires a 25 times play through
restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details
got a gaming problem there's help call
1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it and tell them uncle
joey sent you
but first download the draftking
sportsbook app
and use code church it's monday
[ __ ]
kick this [ __ ] muley oh
[ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today all
right no more [ __ ] excuses this is
the year
of the [ __ ] soldier we're going in
like [ __ ] marines
welcome to church [ __ ]
[Music]
go sick welcome to the church of what's
happening now everybody i am ryan
sickler sitting in tonight
not really in but in and next to uh the
one and only
joey coco diaz here also lee syett
uh this is a special edition i guess of
the church you've never had anyone do
this before no this is an honor
tonight you should like freddie prince
yeah host
joan john rivers will come along yeah
i'm your first guest host
yes [ __ ] love it and i love that
you're here for it though a lot of times
guest hosts and
you're not here somebody else so uh we
have been documenting your life on the
honeydew we have uh
done about 40 hours and we're only at
1980.
[Music]
we got through 1985 and 86 last time on
the honeydew so why don't we pick up
here
with january of 1987.
january of 1987 i found myself working
at a car wash and boulder drying off
cars
i was one of those guys outside freezing
freezing drying off cars i started the
job
like the second week of december and i
worked damn
minimum wage plus tips all right
so just let me refresh here how old are
you in 87 now how old are you
24 okay yeah 24
63 and 4 24. so
i'm wiping down windows washington cars
and the only hustle i have are the tips
how can i steal the tips
how can i steal this you know what i'm
saying if you break up the tips
i go from making seven to like 980.
that's not gonna work for uncle joey
i hate to kick up my income so i figured
out that if i drive the car and the guy
tips me
if nobody's watching it goes in my
pocket oh you said hey
yeah here i am getting the nickel and i
gotta share it with these [ __ ] mooks
that are
moving up the speed of me so that lasted
for a few weeks and i saw an
ad or somebody told me about a body shop
that was hiring a detailing apprentices
now i wasn't [ __ ] getting rich at the
car wash
i went down to this uh whatever the [ __ ]
it was
and i apply and the guy happens to be
from new york
this the body shop the body shop paint
shop detailing shop
and he goes i am looking for a big guy
but it's it may not be you
i got a position for a position called
the shagger
and uh where you you you watch cars
you help the body guys you got to be
here at six in the morning
it doesn't pay overtime it pays like 220
a week
and you're here till you're here and you
work hard to become
a detailer and that's where you make
your money
well i started there like in november
january
right before the super bowl the giants
went to the super bowl against somebody
and uh
or maybe the bronco somebody went i
started the week or two before the super
bowl because they invited me
to their super bowl party they were nice
guys and you know whatever
i fit in but i didn't you know um
i did i did my job i was really good at
it
i used to have to go to car dealers so
this particular
body shop worked for a chain called the
crouches
in boulder at that time they had suzuki
subaru
you know uh acura he had like four or
five
mitsubishi he had like four or five
different chains
and we watched those cars and honda
metro honda we had or something honda
so i became friendly with all the guys
hey hey you doing what's going on
i would help the detailers and pick up
cars
and i became friendly with this guy from
jersey on a subaru dealership
i would go to the subaru dealership
they'd be like the ice cream man got
there
what's up [ __ ] what up oh [ __ ]
there he is
jersey joe oh [ __ ] there was a skinny
guy from detroit that looked like a
junkie real good looking
he was cool the guy's name was peter
pinto the manager
there was a dude named carlos and i just
became friends with him the lot boy
there
was working a tremendous scam he was
selling he was getting like
he was one of those guys that was making
350 an hour but he was making 80
000 a year yeah what i'm saying he was
one of those guys
have you got an above ground pool
he was getting maybe 10 an hour but he
drove like a porsche
because he was taking the subarus this
sl-10
that the high-end stereos and
while you bought the car he would come
up to you and go let me talk to you
about something
what do you want to do here this stereo
sucks what if
i could put an sl10 in there if 100
falls out of your pocket
and he would all send the bank came one
day and they're like all the sl10
[ __ ] radios are missing
they're all shitty am radios it's
[ __ ] hilarious this place
was a big
this place is crazy so now they yelling
at me
when are you gonna become a salesman and
i'm like i'm no [ __ ] car salesman
stop that [ __ ] that's the third guy
in like that three years that kept
bothering me to go sell cars
i'm like i'm not gonna go [ __ ] sell
cars you people are [ __ ] crazy
so i kept and i got promoted to a
detailer
and that's when you get like i forget
what the
but the pay raise was huge i went from
making 220 to like a thousand a week
now i'm doing some powder i got a little
apartment in south boulder
my girlfriend would come over i'd give
her a couple bumps
eat a little monkey she'd go home and
i'd do the rest of
i'd hold out on a i only got a little
bit
[Laughter]
i have to go to school anyway you suck i
thought you got more get the [ __ ] out
and then
i do my thing and
it was great i loved detailing i really
liked it i liked this the
being alone i liked listening to music
everybody there smoked pot
you know it was really cool but one of
my best pieces of work there
was once i started leaning
i became a detailer right away like they
said it takes 90 days
it took me like 24 days and they had no
choice
i was out working everybody i was just
one of those dudes that even with a
monkey on my back
i'm not working you i ain't working for
220 a week
but the thing that kept me there was a
burrito lady
it was a burrito lady that came every
day at like nine o'clock with green
chili and mashed potatoes
in a burrito lee your head would explode
it was in a blender
she'd put it in the blender you could
taste the little pieces of pork in there
so just a tortilla
and you could pay her on friday oh [ __ ]
oh she was beautiful i loved it but then
i was getting hot cigarettes at the time
i had a friend who was giving me hot
cigarettes
i go you sell cigarettes on the roads
coach he goes yeah i'll trade you
cigarettes for [ __ ] burritos
[Music]
it never ends the hustle never ends
doug you don't understand never and
never ended
what's the conversion how many
cigarettes for a burrito i don't know i
forget those days she would i don't know
what she was giving me picard
and then i would get the burritos for
like a dollar off they were like two
dollars a dollar
really delicious i mean you couldn't
live without it that made me hungry
i would snort coke thinking about that
burrito
at the end of this [ __ ] i'm getting six
of those [ __ ] for breakfast
and got every once in a while she'd run
out of them before she get to my stop
like well give me a six potato i'm all
out what do you mean you're all one
you know i need two to make this party
happen here
i don't want the red pork do i look like
i want red pork i'm trying to [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
that was like and i became partners for
the dude who was on steroids
and one night i went to his house after
work he's like he kept
telling me he wanted me to do him a
favor wait i'm just hold on one second
partner's in the detailing business now
no he was a detailer
okay big yo kid and everyone often did
your own thing now
no no no me and him were goombas
he watched my back i watched he was a
big white boy
good [ __ ] dude good family but i went
to his house can you come over with me
and help me
with some stuff at the house i go yeah i
didn't know what to expect
i go where that guy goes listen man me
and my girlfriend broke up and she's the
only way to shoot me with steroids
huh can you shoot me with star wars
i don't know about shooting nobody i
can't even see needles
i could do it you can do it i'll talk
you through it
i mean and then i'm like i don't want to
do this
like you should you should do some
steroids you got a great bill
you lift and i'm like i'm not shooting
and i drank a bottle of steroid juice
that must have definitely [ __ ] myself
up i just drank it my face turned red
for like an hour
so this is i'm talking i'm [ __ ] like
i'm out of my mind guys i'm snorting
coke on the weekends smiley steroid
juice
i drank a whole container of decadent
one of those little syringes
god knows it's gonna happen so it's
supposed to be shot intravenously yeah
so this is how [ __ ] nuts i was
at the time i'm living with like another
couple and they're just doing
coke all the time she's walking around
with her panties
he would pass out and she come talk to
me with the panties
and i you know it was just not a good
scene so
i got my own apartment i moved somewhere
else
and it raised me up a little bit like my
numbers
you know like now i had to pay real rent
i was paying like for a room
and a house now i had to pay real rent
and i was making money detailing but
this cut into my [ __ ]
cocoa local time because i used to go to
[ __ ] in
that one place that serves the french
fries with the endless
red robin red robin he used to make coco
locos
i'd make a tip like two extra vodkas in
there
they make the best top shelf margarita
in the country at the time for 450
red robin my credit card restaurant
margarita margarita margarita
red robin red bra i would go to red
robin every night
do two margaritas two two top shelves do
two bumps
and [ __ ] it from there whatever you need
me to do i'll do it you know what i'm
saying
i would have a little car sale and he'd
drive me home he kept asking me you
don't have no more coke no
i did it all i had to grab my pocket i'd
go home
and [ __ ] bang out blow and then i got
promoted
now i'm thinking about the salesman [ __ ]
the guy told me what they're making over
there and it was a lot more than what i
was making
i'm like should i go with himself
[ __ ] cars
i don't know a lot about cars and these
are the same ones the acura's the
subarus the mitsubishi this is the
supers
okay so these guys back then they had to
what the brat they were the one with the
seats in the back remember those
suicides yeah
he's not the brat he had a bunch of
great cars back then
so i'm i'm gonna be this real decisive
mode but what happened was
there was a crew of detailers and this
just happens to me in all places
what happened was i started out working
them
i started how to figure out the system
the system was to do
two new cars a day and three used cars
that's where your money's at the two new
cars with easy money you just rip the
paper off
you got to put a certain chemical on
them take the cosmoline off
you put the rims on you armor all the
inside you put the mats down
you wash the car and you dry it that's
it
it's no big deal nobody's ever sat in
the car you just got to put the hub
caps on put the [ __ ] mats in
you know a couple things you got to
adjust
set the stations whatever the [ __ ] they
want then you take it to the thing
i could do two of those in an hour so i
would make two [ __ ] runs and they
never heard of that
i'm like why go make runs and pick them
up let's get two done
and i did two canoe cars by 11 and then
i jump on three used cars
i was making some good [ __ ] money but
they started [ __ ] with me
you know they wouldn't give me a bay
they would go oh if you could park two
cars out there
we could put two cars in here so it's
like really four against three and the
supervisor
liked them so i'm like this supervisor
really wants to [ __ ] with me
and then like a week after that one day
he goes i'm gonna [ __ ] write you up
for insubordination something crazy
because i told them i'll do the car
outside no big deal
you can't do it outside i go relax watch
your [ __ ] tone
and then but the manager was from new
york and the manager knew i was a little
[ __ ] up
and the owner was a great white dude you
know those white dudes that drink
whiskey
and they don't watch porn but they
appreciate a good sense of humor like
you could tell that the dude was uptight
and [ __ ] yeah he was just a great white
dude but he liked me
because i [ __ ] made money and i
hustled my ass off
you know i was getting in there with him
at six in the morning you weren't
supposed to be there too late
if i started coke till five what's the
difference sit here and look out the
window by myself
i might as well go pick up a piece of
[ __ ] 30 40 at the time
that was my mentality so they started
picking on me
they started [ __ ] with me like they
really are going to [ __ ] with me
and at that time i had the whole body
shop wide i knew where to get weed i
knew where to get coke
i knew who was selling this who was
selling that there was a creepy dude who
installed stereos there
creepy as [ __ ] in what way what was
every day man i went to the strip club
last night
i met this girl melinda her working name
was gunner
you know he was really creepy that's a
fake real name like
just a creepy strip club guy he knew all
the strip clubs when people would talk
about strip clubs he'd come out
and give you cards for vip or this one
he was friends with the bandurano the
banderas bike gang
i got reefer from him i got coke from
him
he sold a bunch of [ __ ] but he had
everything a guy
that was trying to prove something had
tinted windows a loud stereo
tattoos leather jacket a motorcycle a
pit bull
anything that a guy needs to get a
smarter kitty yeah he was just
but he was like a half a [ __ ] but i
kind of liked him
his drugs were good he always told me
about dirty [ __ ] how he would finger
these strippers
and he would [ __ ] him and all this [ __ ]
speaking of drugs can we smoke darn this
you can do
[ __ ] you want you can let your [ __ ]
on fire
so one day this dude
dirk gets in my face
about some [ __ ] i've told this story
before but i don't think i told it to
you ryan sickler i want to hear it now
i'm [ __ ] nuts
i'm 24. fresh out of [ __ ] jersey
i just slept in benches i just went
through that whole [ __ ]
homeless thing you know
now i'm living in boulder but i'm
keeping a lid on it
i got a girlfriend i have to go to a
family's house every sunday to eat
they're very nice people
they're from buffalo
they're from buffalo new york they're
very nice people i appreciate them
so i gotta act like a [ __ ] man and
these people get in my faces
so there was particularly two white
dudes both from minneapolis minnesota
that would [ __ ] with me and they had a
and they would beat me because they had
the
the [ __ ] the supervisor the
supervisor in that corner
so one day i see the supervisor walking
in
and i don't know what he took his jacket
off and he hung it up
and i don't know what made me do this
but this is the mind of joey diaz you
know
the dude thought he got over on me yeah
but i'm gonna show him
i'm gonna get over on him i just didn't
know how and
all of a sudden the good lord
does something he does every [ __ ] day
he kills a mouse
i turn around and there's a dead mouse
four foot for me maybe
three inches long i see that everybody's
washing cars i go what can i do with
this mouse
i get a paper towel i pick it up by the
tail and i put it in the guy's pocket
the supervisor's pocket i put in this
pocket i get high i keep working on cars
i forget about the whole thing
the next morning i'm in there six
o'clock buzzing out of the car
and you hear a car come in like
and he gets on the car he goes what the
[ __ ] shot it down
shut it down i just got into a major car
accident
he goes i reach in my pocket for
cigarettes and somebody put a mouse in
there
by the end of the day i'm gonna find out
who it is i have an idea who it is and
i'm [ __ ]
you know me dawg i'm like i'll help you
find the [ __ ] yeah that's son of a [ __ ]
but that [ __ ] knew it was me or
some other guy his car was all crashed
up
[ __ ] him [ __ ] so right there i knew it
was time for me to go
so about april 15th all right
we're in april now everybody april 1986
i tell the [ __ ]
i tell the [ __ ] uh the [ __ ] car
the dealership the i caught him a deal
i tell the detail guys that
i'm gonna go sell cars for one day and
try it
and after one day i'll know if i like it
or not
and they said okay when do you want to
do this i go monday
so i put together what i had as a suit
at that time and i went there monday
they told me to be that eight to learn
about some cars
and they gave me to this guy named jimmy
wheeler god rest herself i stood up to
his son
i still talked to his son that's amazing
do you remember the cody wheeler
i remember this guy's name because he
was the first guy that made me feel like
family without being at home
he was one of those guys that he was
willing to take a bullet for you
and again god put this guy in my life
and on the first day he just dug me
we were big time bruce lee fans that's
why i brought you this shirt thank you
for that shirt
and he had the tower ji kundo signed by
bruce lee
nobody had that at the time and he was
from detroit he just
impressed the [ __ ] out of me and he gave
me a shirt once detroit the murder
capital of the united states of america
it was my favorite shirt i wore it all
summer long
people said to me why do you wear that
shirt it's disgusting i [ __ ] love
detroit
i want to go to [ __ ] detroit like i
i'm ready for detroit [ __ ] these [ __ ]
like that's how crazy i was at the time
and
that first day with jim wheeler i ended
up selling three cars making
a thousand bucks on paper and like two
hundred and spits
cash at seven o'clock i called the body
shop and told him to suck my dick
i'm never washing the car again
went to my mother-in-law god bless her
soul my ex-mother-in-law who
i loved daily at the time and she lent
me her
uh may dnf card and she let me charge
500
i bought three suits shirts
pants and i was all in guys
you were selling cars in denver well not
denver older and the first month i ended
up selling 14 cars
damn i was the same that's every other
day damn near i was a salesman
of the month i think i came in second
did you get a special spot and all that
[ __ ]
yeah like i got a demo for free you had
to sell 12 cars to get your car for free
or you had to pay 300 a month so that
was the magic number 12 you get your
demo
and then they had weird bonuses like
once you sell
10 cars your bonus goes from 20 to 30
11 cars 35 12 cars 40
uh 15 cars
40 plus a 500 cash bonus
they worked it plus every new subaru you
called
every new subaru you sold you ripped the
thing
and you looked at it and they will
either give you money or you spun the
wheel you called subaru
and they tell you you won 350 and you'll
get your check in the mail
so the first month i think i made like
eight grand are you kidding me i paid my
mother-in-law back
i went out and bought some really nice
suits and i was all in
oh this is me i bought the nicest shirts
i got them dry cleaned
i cut my hair don't get me wrong i was
doing coke
four out of five nights don't forget to
lay that in there
i'm saying don't forget to lay that in
there because that's the truth i [ __ ]
snorted coke i had a girlfriend who i
loved i'd been with her at the time
at the time we had been together for two
and a half years
it was a rough two and a half years but
we loved each other
she was living with her mother i got an
apartment
uh we were young you know
and during the week she would stay home
and i would
leave the dealer at nine
three nights a week actually went home
changed uh
marinated the steak one in the garage
lifted weights
and then cooked the steak eat it and i'd
go to bed at 11 11 30.
but four nights a week i was pretty much
[ __ ]
come home with three margaritas in me
go in my bedroom put the pajamas on get
the coke out
sneak a bottle in there and only come
out to go to the bathroom because i had
three other roommates
i had three i had a chick a little
chubby chick that was beautiful
my parents owned the printing shop i had
a guy that was part of toastmasters and
i had like
a white guy that was just a creepy guy
that went in a boat every day
that's all he did what'd you do today i
wanted about where in the river what are
you doing
no i didn't really talk to them yeah i
didn't go to the community room at night
i sat in the back and i was tight with
the red head the red head sold weed
so we kind of became tight so i had a
dog
named hercules tried to go home and walk
the dog every day and do that [ __ ]
and one day a new salesman came in his
name was kent vela
i want to ask you two questions real
quick you said ex-mother-in-law
right do you even talk about marriage
yet
right she you know that's who she is
we'll get to that right we'll get copy
that now
she was the mother of the girl i was
dating at the time
got it i want to ask you about being a
salesman because you said you were all
in so you probably liked it
you seemed like you liked it at least
right the parallels between
i find that because i have a friend of
mine that's a salesman between
stand up and salesman is so there are a
lot of similarities like you got to get
them
within that first six years until you
become a comedy salesman you'll never
become a comic
that's right you could write jokes all
you want
until you learn how to sell them you'll
never become a comic and that's what
happened with me
i i took my comedy my car sell
and i wanted to go into the selling mode
of it
you know it's completely different so
but it's an interesting blueprint to
apply instead of try hey buy this car
it was the best thing that i ever did in
my life [ __ ] yeah
it gave me a purpose i went in there in
the mornings i did it
i watched the guy that was doing the
best and i mimicked him
and what does that mean uh how you doing
lisa what's going on he was very nice to
you he pushed a little bit
is there something we could do today to
get you out of that car well my wife's
not here well
does your wife [ __ ] you know he don't
talk to him like that these were white
people in boulder
you couldn't break that ball yeah you
know there's some people
i'll take a look at the numbers okay and
there's some people let me come back
and you bring them inside professionally
sit them down and set an appointment
with them i did all that stuff
and when they gave me a card i would
call mr syed how are you
tomorrow when you come in before you
come in what do you mean tomorrow i
remind you you have an appointment
tomorrow one o'clock
i want you to have questions prepared
for me for the car
like you know these are how you become a
salesman
uh if he comes in and looks at the car
and gets a number next morning i come in
i write a letter
yeah and yeah back then back then when
you hand written a letter
it means something not like a letter
that says
dear and i put in uh ryan
and i signed it at the bottom you know
what i'm saying no no so you had to do
all those steps
and i really believed them and subaru
was great to work for
the first two months was great to work
for them
then the third month it was great to
work with then things started going a
little sour
when you're a salesman the third month
you you sell cars the first two months
because you're stupid
you're stupid but then the third month
now you believe
you drink your own gin you drink your
own juice
and you go i i sold like four cars my
third month
and it cracked me what did you think did
you think you weren't good did you think
[ __ ] changed what was it that
started [ __ ] with it it was just
everything plus i was starting to do
coke
a lot there like it was known
as a coke dealership like i still
remember you said a coke dealer
everybody was doing okay they were if
the
the manager did it the assistant manager
did it if there was
12 salesmen eight salesmen did it
you know it was two i remember like
being there
when it snowed like in april one day
it snowed and we were shoveling snow and
we were all drinking a bottle of
blackberry brandy
like the manager went and got us all
blackberry brandy
and the whole day we worked all [ __ ]
up on blackberry brains yeah i mean i
did have
but i really believed in it i wasn't
stealing at the time
i was the only sin i was doing was doing
coke
i was with my girlfriend on the weekends
i was with her from saturday to sunday
night you know
she'd spend saturday night with me we'd
do a little [ __ ] tootsie-roots
and then my behavior changed the third
month
i bought a car from them
i i said let me i go don't buy one of
these [ __ ] used cars of course
what is it about did did the state of
colorado
because i feel like everybody's got a
subaru out there did they did is there a
did they welcome subaru in or something
like that it just works when you see
they're everywhere what happens you
could look at me and go i hate that
[ __ ] subaru
go to colorado bring your car good luck
yeah come see me in november when you're
spinning around the circle you get the
four-wheel drive because your car's not
that heavy there's something
it's just too much once you see it once
you see a car perform like that
in that type of weather that stays with
you forever
you know i don't know how many times i
saw a cadillac
and the whole family's like what are we
doing you're in your subaru doing 90 up
the hill
vote for me why would you buy a car if
they were giving you one for free
because i just wanted like a you could
buy a car and flip them
wow so i was like maybe i'll flip this
car it was a little toyota
they wanted 1500 bucks but they took
like 3 000 out of my check
and i got pissed on a saturday and i
[ __ ] got an axe handle and i want to
top one of the cars and i said i want my
money i'm going to start breaking
windshields in front of customers and
[ __ ]
and this guy came over because i already
had like here's 500
i already had an eight ball on my mind
you can't do this to me we got paid on
the saturday
and the check was light and i had to pay
rent but there wasn't enough for the
eight ball
i already told the guy i was coming he
already had it what do you mean you got
money for the eight ball
it's a really weird dynamic with just
what
what's about to happen in my life
when i'm screaming and yelling i'm gonna
break the windshield
jim wheeler who's my brother comes out
he's like joey you're overreacting
peter pinto who comes up says joey
you're reacting
i was mad at peter i'm like you lied to
me on this [ __ ] deal
you told me 1500 you didn't say nothing
about 800 dealers
[ __ ] tax and all this [ __ ] and he's
like get off the car
we'll talk about it i'm like i'm not
getting off the car how many people are
out there you think what
30 people i'd be over there
i will break this [ __ ] glass right
now if i don't get my money
and there was a guy if i was
24 this guy was about
42 48
tough guy still built
i could tell he came from something i
just didn't know what
we got into a misunderstanding one day
over a customer at the last moment
he came over and said and he gave me the
guy's car and i'm like what's this and
he goes i talked to the guy two days ago
i go so you've been sitting there for
two hours seeing me work with the guy
it's just a guy talk to you didn't jump
in now
when the deal is done you want to throw
your car and i took the car and i threw
it back at him
that don't work that way dawg anglers
you did not disrespect me like that i go
think about what you're doing to me
you're disrespecting me and he's like
you know
if you liked it we could go outside like
you want to [ __ ] go outside and all
of a sudden
all hell broke all hell broke loose you
know i didn't throw
my hands he didn't throw his i told him
to relax
you know i'll [ __ ] you up you guys went
outside there was a bunch of holding
them back
everybody held us back we went to the
opposite corners
and that was it we avoided each other
for like two weeks
three weeks we just avoided each other
we cut a deal
i told him take 200 out that's it he
agreed to it
and uh that was it and
in the middle of all this yelling and
screaming that same guy
comes over and he goes joseph joseph
like a what and he goes how much money
do you need
500 get down
he peels off fire he goes here can i
talk to you for a second sir
and i go yeah and he goes i please
advise you to go home
you're going to ruin it for us and we're
not going to sell no cars here you're
not going to sell no cars in the
condition you're in
and i'm like you're like a nosey
[ __ ] aren't you
but you gave me a nickel i'm not gonna
argue with you i didn't get my cocaine
i'll take that 500 and your two cents
and i'm like
my buddy carlos valverde drove me home
and i went and got my coke and the whole
thing more happened but i don't want to
talk
like this was a wild day carlos asked me
to use the bathroom
two hours in the bathroom he comes out
la bomba
lava yeah you know he's deep into the la
bomba powder
and he leaves i mean i'm living in i'm
surrounded
so i go back monday
we work out the car you know what
i didn't need this in my life i had a
buddy who worked down the corner
at the christ department store let me go
down there with him
those are white people they're the
hollisters
it's these two [ __ ] brothers the
father [ __ ]
drove down the town the stagecoach so
i'm supposed to be impressed
it's two [ __ ] brothers they bought
the first dodge dealership in town who
do i give a [ __ ]
i go down there they're the nicest white
people in the world can i just say this
is what i love about you
so far we have robbed jewelry stores
we have robbed gas stations now we're
hustling
auto dealerships you said you seem to
gravitate to one
and then hustle the circuit then you're
on to the nasty
you're like different seasons i'm gonna
be as honest to god with everybody
when i was at bill crouch subaru those
first 90 days
i took i took my job very seriously i
didn't steal nothing
i knew that the lot boy was stealing i
smoked pot behind the building
i mean again that's not stealing that
ain't called
i really tried to turn my life around
let's get that straight
the ghost of cocaine was still calling
me
i still had little bits of anger from my
stepdad
but uh nothing seriously nothing
the addiction was the most important
thing what it was becoming
it was silent i go over to hollister i
get the [ __ ] appointment and i get
the job
i start working at hollister maybe may
15th
now your car salesman for dodge chrysler
you said let's say
i start working over there maybe june
july dodge chrysler now
dodge chrysler i sell chrysler
and they sell dodge across the way i
could sell
i sell chrysler i could sell dodge if i
have to but i don't want to go over that
because they call themselves the dodge
boys so
i didn't have time to [ __ ] hang out
with
all the dodge boys
oh that's a good one
for this right here that sounded so wet
that's garlic that's supposed to be what
so
i go to work for the houses and you know
what happens to me over there man
i meet a jewish guy that is one of the
best jewish men i've ever met in my life
his name is art preston and art
knew the science of selling he was a
college graduate he was from the bronx
he was a big [ __ ] jew six foot
whatever
sloppy but when it came to selling he
was a bet when he got up
if he got up off his desk you're buying
a car
he was intimidating and [ __ ] up not
that he was he was
intimidating he was jewish but it had a
sweetheart
that only a jew would have there was two
jews in that town like that there was
em and dr mazalka dr mazalka was a big
ass jew that delivered babies
and he was the bronx he was from the
bronx him and his wife were both
doctors in the same house calls and [ __ ]
no no no no they delivered babies
but they were pediatricians but they
they were a team
the wife was like this model and then
the husband was a guy like me but only
six foot four
had 50 pounds and he would walk in and
go hey
you gained some weight this month and
you everybody wanted to
have a baby with misoka because he had
saved
a child one time when a woman was dying
so people actually scheduled their kids
so they could have misoka take their
kids out
that's how busy his practice was so
we'll get into that later right now
let's leave it but it was art presley
had that gift
when our president got up i don't care
what you were a part
i don't care if you wanted your payment
to be 350.
he was getting you for 480. i don't know
how he did it
and he started showing me how to do it
but our president also had a vice he
sold coke
i can't get away with it i can't get
away from him
he made a call he made he used to make a
call and the guy would come
but the business was so good at that job
that he just used to have the guy come
and drop an ounce off
and each salesman would take an eight
ball he was [ __ ] crazy
there was four salesmen one kid was a
great kid from like south dakota
i used to burn him on weed he used to
buy weeds with me and i used to spray
water in it
and make it heavier then they get back
to south dakota it was like a pound less
like what the pound left people would be
getting back hands the indians would be
smacking them
then there was another guy that looked
like lee harvey oswalt
that he was kind of creepy he would get
so coked up
he would people would bang on his window
sir sir
can you help us with a car and he'd go
go away go away
that's how coked up he would get but
there was this one guy that was a coke
fiend
super salesman and it was me against him
every [ __ ] month and i would beat him
by a
witch's tit what's your uh like what
kind of number are you doing on a month
like that are you in the teens
like what's up that place if you sold 10
cars you were a [ __ ] superstar
yeah a month that was a free car a
bonus after seven cars it was free
and every car after that was 500 but it
was a mom-and-pop store it closed at
eight
yeah people went in there you couldn't
really pressure
but 120 cars a year out of that's what
you got to pull if you're doing 10 a
month
i was pulling like six grand a month
over there i wasn't getting rich and
after taxes i really wasn't getting rich
guys
but it was good money for a [ __ ] 24
yeah yeah
it was great money i dressed nice i
looked nice
i felt good about myself but i still had
that monkey on my back
and then i started wiring the place i
had my buddy come into town
and i got him a job on the lot on the
lot and he started [ __ ]
you know terrorizing like me and him
were just
that's what we did you get both of us
together in your business
your business is done your business is
done
by august i was i'm snorting up a storm
i'm the kid robbed the super salesman
he started selling coke because art
didn't want to sell it no more
but rob would snort it and leave it in
the office he would hide it
and i would watch where he'd hide it so
i'd buy coke from him
and then at six in the morning when
service opened i would shoot down there
run in the office go in the ceiling take
coke off
murray package put aspirin powder in
there
close them up and put them back in the
ceiling you can't imagine this
i did this to him for like a month on
top of that i was pulling the poor
a torture chamber on him he used to love
he always believed he sold more cars
when he had a red parker pen
there was a mall across the street that
sold pens things remembered
mm-hmm and i figured out a way how to
rob them i would go get you [ __ ]
engraved and all that go over there and
get it ask them how to get a cross pen
and then they would open the thing they
would open it
they would open the thing and they'd
walk away and they'd steal all the pens
i mean i was crazy
at this place i went crazy i got the key
to the soda machine
it was my own personal atm i would go in
and just steal the change
and the guy would leave cash he would
leave cash for the change like 200
i would take the 200 it was we were
running a muck over there i mean i was
totally out of control
i was selling wheat to the indians every
saturday
i was buying it from the creepy guy at
the strip club
oh the body shop yeah okay the white guy
so this goes on over there at
at this [ __ ] thing we're going to
september
we're i remember the twins when the
world series or something like that
the twins yeah yeah 87 maybe
the twins are in the world should be
somebody somebody weird
i remember i started the world series
there the cocaine got so bad there
that the general manager came up and
said
i gotta break this ring up you guys
are way below average like whatever the
[ __ ] is going on
we were four guys that did not want to
talk to people we were either up from
the night before
or we were just getting blasted i mean
there was a room there
that they had coffee and cookies if you
were in the cabinet
they had every type of booze there it
became a really toxic place for me
i was living on jack jack
jack-in-the-box
seafood and crab salad oh
jack-in-the-box used to have a
seafood and crab salad i thought i was
eating that and i was healthy
it was horrible who was won the twinkies
in that 87. goddammit jelly hands
87 was twins against the cardinals there
you go you bad [ __ ]
because the indian kid was cheering for
the twins from minnesota because he's
from south dakota
so all this shit's going on and i don't
know what happened
i got into i really can't i don't know
what happened people
next thing you know i get into an
argument with them and my phone rings
it's my buddy jim wheeler he goes what's
going on down there
and i go you know i'm doing my thing you
know and he goes listen joey
peter pinto's god wayne means is here
now it's a different organization
they've been talking about you know what
do you need you need a little something
to come over
i go ask them to give me a nickel and
i'll be over there tomorrow
and i went up to heart like a man i told
him i'm going to bill crouch and he told
me he goes you're making a mistake joey
we're going to clean this up over here
we're going to expand the dodge don't
leave
don't go to bill crotch they're [ __ ]
crazy over there i go they're making
eight nine ten grand a month
i'm over here if i'm here nine to nine
making five grand
it's a no-brainer i get it it's a
different type of store
there's some people who like that
mom-and-pop feeling i need action
once i'm down for two hours i'm done i
need to talk to people at nine when
people are dropping that car off for
service
as they're walking out what are you
doing here i'm nothing i'm getting a
certain rap
what year and you start talking to me
and that's how you sell a car
because that guy you talked to you
didn't pressure
when you say anything you like nah i
like my car a lot yeah subarus are great
they're tremendous car
but next time you come looking for a car
ask for the cuban
so i go back to bill crowd subaru
and it is the beginning of november of
1987.
it is a rock fest
within the first three [ __ ] days
i make two thousand dollars i mean it is
it was me this guy named storm and
norman owlette
now storming normalette was in the
halfway house
he was he did something he was one of
the best salesmen
i ever saw in my life storming norman
sold the first car of the day
every day like before i got there like
joey what do you see this guy
like he just got out of jail watch
this guy's got like nine kids watch his
magic
but when he was in the halfway house
this is so weird to see
because i even dropped him off at the
halfway house a few nights
in a few nights i do bumps with him and
i go aren't you worried they're going to
catch and he go i got all set up
he would get a hot water bottle with
real piss
and tie it to his body with a hose and
and then take the hose and scotch tape
it to his dick
and he'd let the hose open up i mean he
had a cap on it he knew when they were
going to test
him i'm like you're [ __ ] nuts you go
you do all this to get high and he this
is what he did
you know so it was november of 87
i'm getting [ __ ] up and
one day i pop up and who's there that
kid ken
bella that i met before good looking
young kid
coke fiend him and this guy named tom
holm
were [ __ ] all day like when i worked
with them
as soon as you got that 8 30 at a sales
meeting by nine one of them was in the
car going to a liquor store
and they'd mix and they'd be out there
with cups you think they were drinking
coffee
they were drinking martinis you know
so i'm working with some heavy duty
fiends but jim wheeler had my back
he was i reported directly to him
it was a liner closer store but i closed
my own deals with jim
that was part of my deal and this wayne
means guy
was a great [ __ ] guy but guess who
else was there
the dude who gave me the 500 he was
still working there
and me and him had still had kind of
weird feelings
so
it's like my second day back third day
fifth day back i sold
i made two thousand dollars in five days
and i get there one morning and who's
there but kent
and i go he goes you remember me i go
hey yeah what's happened
what are you bending us oh you have no
idea
at that time i used to read the boulder
paper and there was a lot of drug
things going on a lot of weird cocaine
[ __ ] some guy jumped off of
a balcony the cops were knocking on his
door
he jumped off the balcony and he broke
he broke both legs
uh a cuban kid they
his body disappeared from the university
of boulder campus
uh they can't this car was blood
splattered
they couldn't find the details of what
was going on
and i read about this crazy guy that
escaped from the [ __ ] escape from the
hospital or something like that
and so i'm talking to this valley guy
and i go so where you been
he goes i had to go to arizona for a few
months i had a little problem here
what was the problem he goes well i got
a
dui and i crashed the car
and when they took me to the hospital i
broke into the pharmacy
stole a bottle liquor cocaine and pills
and ran out of there and they caught me
so now they got me on these charges i'm
gonna have to do time
and i go false all you're gonna have to
do is like six or a year
it's no big deal he's like [ __ ] that
they're not putting me in jail
you know they're not putting me in jail
i got a [ __ ] idea so that was
i go you know what kind of idea how the
[ __ ] are you gonna get out of jail you
don't pay an attorney
you just started here you haven't sold
any cars
what is your due date
and he's telling me what his due date is
blah blah blah
and then november of 87 was when the
stock market crashed
okay so we went from selling a bunch of
cars
to dead and still storm and norman
was selling a car a day a day huh a day
the world crashed look at the stock
market crash of 87 what was the date
so that happened and we were on the lot
so there was a lot of desperation on the
lot
so this fella guy
that same morning when i get there and i
meet him
and he says hi after about a half hour
october 20 seconds yeah so right there
it was terrible like i went over there
worked for about a week and then it just
went downhill
and then valor came over the homeboy
still banging one a day out
right one day out so now i'm sitting
there with homeboy
and he says to me can you give me a ride
real quick i have to get some i go why
can't you ride
he goes because he has no driver's
license he goes when i sell a car i have
to split with everybody
so you'll be my partner on every car
deal which was nice because now i get
you know and i'll take care of him
so i get a car and i where you guys
going he needs to go to the post office
so i had a p.o box but next was a liquor
store
it was 9 15 in the morning gentlemen
that [ __ ] went into the liquor
store
came out with a bottle of vodka and
started drinking it like it was [ __ ]
coffee
takes off this cocaine and gives me a
blast of it and it's super duper [ __ ]
coke
and we go back to the dealership and
he's telling me about
you know can you get any rid of any coke
and i'm like you know i can do whatever
i can do i can do okay selling coke and
he goes i got this guy the guy i'm
staying with
he goes my i go what is your plan how
are you gonna get out of jail he goes
what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna steal the coke from my
roommate to sell on the street
excuse me make enough money
and go to arizona and hide out
and i go kent that's not a good idea
because there's a thing called a warrant
yeah they're gonna fly it's not hard to
find them it's 87 not 1927.
so i asked him i go how much coat are
you talking about
it goes like two keys
and right away my [ __ ] goes right
up and i'm like this guy's going down
i'll never forget like talking to him
and going in and i could use long
distance at the
dealership i knew the code on the phones
yeah and i still remember calling my
buddies in jersey and them telling me
what they're doing the parties they have
in hunter
mountain they're getting [ __ ] up that
one night they were getting chased by
cops
and they threw coke out the window and
the next day they went back and there
was a bunch of dig
deer that were dead eating the coke
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you guys
talking about
and they're like what the [ __ ] are you
doing with your life in colorado get
back
you're missing a party we're snorting
every [ __ ] night
nobody's got jobs we're all getting
taken care of i'm like
[ __ ] it i'll be on the next plane and
i'm coming with a package
i'm gonna rob this [ __ ] guy so
i take this guy home that night and i'm
milking him for more information
i'm like how much money are you looking
for the two kilos and he's like i don't
know what he told me
you know and i go you know what i know a
guy
so i ran home i ran back to the
dealership and i called my buddy
god rest his soul damn radio and i go
darren
i got a pigeon bro if you come out here
we could take this [ __ ] down
and it's two kilos it's pure
and he tells me he goes coco i can't i
got this job
because this was like a rush job this is
like
we're going in like in two days we gotta
do this so
i go home that night and my buddy was
living with me he was my brother he's my
best friend
i know his mother i know his grandmother
they took me in their house
i could ask him to do it but i didn't
feel right
i didn't want to i don't like taking
people down dark streets
if that's what you want to do i'll give
you work
but i'm not going to talk lee into
robbing a bank that's not fair to lee
i'm not that type of person i've never
been that type of person
if lee comes to me and he goes joey i
want to [ __ ] ten hookers and get my
balls licked
i go do you have two thousand dollars
and you'll go no i'll go well i do know
a place
where there's three thousand dollars and
if you help me rob it i'll give you the
two to get your boy
if you could do that i can make that
happen let's go take this [ __ ]
down i was one of those guys
oh you need that okay well if you need
this i'm the type of guy that i know
where there's five grand
but you got to go home and get you your
mop or a knife you got to do something
it's very helpful you got to earn your
keep you got to be a half a lookout you
got to kick somebody in the stomach
you got to do something so half a
lookout yeah you got to be half a look
i work with a half a lookout so
i dropped this velo off and i go home
and i'm banging my head off the wall
of how i'm gonna rob this guy because no
matter what i'm gonna have to show him
some cash i got a flash
if he's looking for 40 or 30 i got a
flash 10 adam
for him to open up and then i'll just
take the kilo and the 10 back
you know what i'm saying like you know
me i'll work it one way or the other
so i'm banging my head for two [ __ ]
days
how the [ __ ] and he's bringing coke to
work and this coke is
electric it's real
1987 powder
you know just beautiful you could smell
it before you walked in the room
i mean it was just perfect i could have
cut it and made a [ __ ] payday with it
the girl i'm dating at the time
we're not doing so good we were together
four years but the relationship was a
little stale since she moved in with her
mother
the first three years of our
relationship we were together all day
now we're like
you know we see each other twice during
the week
and then we'd mess around the weekends
but it was usually drug related we'd
start getting high saturday night
you know it was kind of weird she was
graduating from some like
hair cutting salon and i didn't go to
the graduation
i was too busy selling cars so we didn't
talk
like two or three days and in those two
and three days i figured out that the
only guy that was gonna help me
rob this [ __ ] fella guy
was the goofy guy with the motorcycle
and the pitbull
yeah i started okay so i go to him
and i kind of tell him what's going on
and he's like that's perfect
because i was looking for a big heist i
go what are you looking for a house or
whatever he goes no
and right here i should have known i
should have shot myself
he goes nah ah he goes
there's this stripper i'm in love with
my name is jennifer i don't know if her
name was jennifer guys i'm just using a
name
here he tells me her name is jennifer or
whatever
that he's got a problem she's living on
his
he's he's she's living in his house
she's living in his bedroom but he's
sleeping on the couch
because she wants to be with him but she
can't
because she's catholic and she's still
married
and until she gets divorced she can't be
with him
wait a second you met her at an all-nude
byob
all nude and the woman was gorgeous
let's not get me wrong here
i would cut somebody's finger off of
this broth
okay so i've never heard anybody
somebody's finger was coming off of this
broad she was beautiful
big tate's nice juicy ass she was
beautiful to
have spanish white just a knockout she
was
she was working this poor [ __ ] idiot
so he goes i'm in i'm in i'll rob him
with you
so we set it up for the following
tuesday
like all weekend i'm stalling them he's
like you got to get a buyer you got to
get a buyer i got a buyer
but i'm making them come tell them i got
the indians from south dakota
they're going to send somebody down give
me till tuesday
till tuesday tuesday
and the whole weekend went by he's
calling me one and i'm going over there
picking up coke give me a little
gram on the arm until tuesday until the
indians come nobody don't know
nothing and he's stealing from his
roommate the whole [ __ ] thing
and tuesday comes tuesday morning comes
i got a call from
tidwell that was the idiot with the car
and the dogs and [ __ ]
and he goes my mother owns a house
on 28th street is vacant
bring them over there
we'll get him to bring the coke
before i flash the money i'll rob me
both ears
handcuff both of you and then i'll leave
and i'll split the money with you
i like the idea but i didn't
i don't know i don't want to get
handcuffed with nobody there was no cell
phones in those days
and also just don't trust anybody and i
just knew that this guy
something wasn't right so i wake up that
morning
november tuesday the 18th 1987
i got a dental appointment like tomorrow
at nine in the morning i got a dental
appointment
it was only two that's my cocaine tooth
yeah it cracked the out there that was
my original cocaine tooth when i stopped
doing coke that duke was black
and i went to the dentist this [ __ ]
jewish guy in beverly hills
he wanted two thousand just went to walk
in he was one of those dentists
because he was like jamie lee curtis
yeah all right
somebody like thought like that's a
dentist i needed i asked a friend like
do you have a dentist
yeah he's in beverly hills what there's
none in the valley so
uh this guy told me he goes your little
cocaine tooth
he knew it's gonna cost like 25 000. i'm
like
a thousand i'm like i don't have 25 000.
i go uh he goes what do you have it's
like three days before christmas i go
500 and he goes i'm gonna put a cap on
it
it's only gonna last for about six
months well it lasted thirteen years
did it really it fell off during [ __ ]
covert i'm walking
i can't even smile i'm thankful for the
[ __ ] mess
i look like hillbilly joe walking around
so i [ __ ] uh
set it up for tuesday at one o'clock
in the afternoon the plan was
i go pick him up he gets the blow brings
it
we walk in he robs us he takes the coke
he goes to a certain spot we
walk out of there when i get home i call
tidwell
and we split the take that was the plan
i did not like it i felt i was gonna get
cheated some way or another
so i go let me figure let's see how we
could do this
maybe i could get to this before this
so i call vella he tells me to pick him
up
i go to his house and the funny thing is
that when i pull up in front of his
house
i make a mental note that he lives
across my halfway house
from bctc where i used to drive normal
lead at night
okay this is [ __ ] weird this is how
weird life is
i even made a mental note he's right
there by storming norman
so i go upstairs it's about 12 in the
after 12 o'clock
i walk in i give him a hug he's already
jazzed up
this kid had been up for like three days
he goes you want to align yeah
we go in the room we do a line he opens
up the drawer and he shows me the bottom
of a grinder
and it's pretty much filled
next to the grinder there's about 2 000
in cash
and next to the cash there's a baggie
with like a loose ounce
and i go where the kilos where the kilos
at
and he goes the kilos are in the ceiling
in the living room you have to push up
the ceiling tile
and then get the kilo he goes it's in
the middle so
what i'm going to do is is just take a
sample
so right there i'm [ __ ] i go no you
got to bring it all this guy wants to
buy it all he just don't want a sample
he goes no i'm going to give him a nice
eight ball
sample that's in here and there's still
a baggie here that's an ounce
because he we went in there and did a
couple bumps first
and it was all rocky it was close to an
ounce
so he closes the draw
and i'm like i'm already [ __ ]
i hope that tidwell is smart enough
that when he gets down there he can
flash the cash
and we come back and rob this [ __ ]
guy once and for all
so me and vela get in my car
we drive down to [ __ ] uh
whatever's place now for sake of
argument
i could i could you know
i have a weapon in the trunk
that i had had from 85 and aspen
when i was buying guns i always kept one
nine millimeter
i didn't plan on using it there was
nothing
i walked in the house with
said well first of all there's no
[ __ ] furniture
i'm like walking into the irishman
furniture you might as well put plastic
on the floor
so he comes out with his [ __ ] pimple
why is the pit bull here
hopefully he's like did you bring the
stuff and we're like yeah show him kent
kent shows him the coke and he [ __ ]
pulls out
a gun immediately immediately
immediately and then
throws a machine gun at me and he goes
joey tie him up
so now i'm the bad guy oh [ __ ] now you
just drew me into the [ __ ] you
dumb [ __ ] so the kids looking at
me like what's going on here i go
listen we're taking that coke you know i
had to break the bad news to him
he's like you can't i need that i'm
gonna go to jail i'm like listen
we're taking that code
so this is the dude you've worked with
all this time and everything yeah
so we're taking the coke i'm sorry it's
just thoughts
you know so for me i'm getting a kilo i
could do a lot with a kilo
i could i could sell ten thousand for me
i was gonna get ten thousand
snort to rest and let the pieces fall
where the [ __ ] they made jack
i got 10 000 cash i don't give a [ __ ] 10
000 to me in those days is gonna be a
million dollars so
he uh throws me the gun you know
but there but originally the plan was
for him you're a
i like that i say face and the whole
thing
[ __ ] weird situation
so now this is where it gets tricky you
know it's in court documentation so i'm
not saying nothing out of line
for you people who are waiting for me to
say something out of line
uh tidwell goes i'm gonna go to his
house and check it out
i go go in the drawer
and that's where the coke is at i didn't
tell them nothing about the ceiling
okay i didn't say nothing about the
ceiling for a reason
we take vela into the room we tie him up
we gag him
and we put the pitbull in the room with
him and we tell him not to [ __ ] move
and the whole time he's like joey why
are you doing this to me i feel terrible
to this day this is why i did what i did
for that kid
so this [ __ ] jerk off comes back
and he goes man i didn't find anything
in that draw
i just found 300 hours in an 8 ball
you're lying to me there was an ounce of
coke and
2 000 1800 something like that something
you know
30 [ __ ] years ago what do i know
so i go really that's what you're trying
to tell me
i go well i saw a [ __ ] ounce and i
saw two thousand dollars
he goes that's not what was in the draw
i'm telling you right now i go really
well i'm gonna go over there and take a
look
he goes what am i gonna do with him i go
i don't know you created this [ __ ]
problem
and as i walked to the door he like
clicked the gun
like he's like if you leave i'm gonna be
i'm gonna have to shoot him and shoot
you
i knew this guy couldn't hurt himself
this guy was trying to be a man
worse than anything else in his life and
i remember looking at him going you're
not gonna shoot nobody dog
and i went out of that [ __ ] car and i
had a gun in the trunk
like you know what i should do because
this is not going to end good
but i i look at the situation i'm in
look at what the [ __ ] situation i'm
in this is not going to end good the
only way this ends is by me shooting
both these [ __ ]
[Music]
in a residential area at one o'clock in
the afternoon in boulder colorado
ah yeah i'm like this is and i'm sitting
out there i pop the trunk
i [ __ ] pick up the carpeting i
actually took the gun i looked at it for
a minute
and and something made me think of my
mother something like this is not
i go let me go salvage this [ __ ]
thing and i got in that [ __ ] car made
a u-turn
i shot over there like a bat out of hell
and they had like a kind of half a [ __ ]
door man
like hi welcome to the hotel the regency
house
who are you going to see and then they
would buzz them
when i got out of the car you could tell
my body language
he didn't even ask like he just opened
the [ __ ] door
and i went in i got on the elevator i
went to the door
i didn't even use the key i just kicked
the [ __ ] door down i was so
[ __ ] furious that i had let myself be
taken now
i gotta get whatever pieces i can and
get the [ __ ] out of dodge
i kick the [ __ ] door down i went in
the drawer there was nothing there
and i'll never forget they had like a
coffee thing in the living room
i moved the [ __ ] table out of the way
and i jumped up like a gorilla that i am
i was about 2
20 at the time and i grabbed on to the
whole ceiling
and i just pulled it the [ __ ] all down
half of it came down there was dust
and all of a sudden you just heard both
and it was two [ __ ] rocks a coke
one had been broken into already with a
little bit of a seal
was taped back on i grabbed those
[ __ ] i looked around
i put them in a bag i ran downstairs
when i walked out in the hallway there
was three people in the hallway like
what happened i'm like i don't know
i just walked past him i don't know he's
pointing back
i [ __ ] went downstairs and i'll never
forget just walking out in the doorman
seeing me
and me just i remember i parked my car
away
i had to walk a little bit but i walked
past the halfway house
and i'm like [ __ ] and there's a
newspaper stand on the other edge of the
halfway house
i put the cocaine on the bottom ledge
whenever you got buying newspapers from
now on and you open it up look at the
bottom ledge
that's what all school drug dealers used
to do drugs no [ __ ] so the old school
where you could put a quarter in and
open the door you could take all the
papers yeah
yeah the bottom leg all right i'm just
gonna go pay to see one now
so i hit the coke in the bottom ledge
i ran home i called the buddy of mine
and i told him
warm up a car get a car you got to go to
aspen i called a friend of mine and
asked me
and i said can you still move coke
tonight he goes i can move whatever you
bring me
i go you got two kilos on the way on one
and a half
send me this number whatever number you
could send me
i knew him he was a dear friend of mine
and
within an hour the kid the coke on the
way to aspen
i had gone back and taken like
ah 17 grams out of the bag
and then i went home
and i was like what the [ __ ] do i do now
i have to wait for this guy to go to
aspen
and i don't know what's going to happen
with these two [ __ ] idiots brian
secretly you can't write this [ __ ]
you can't you cannot right that's why
i'm sitting here listening
on that edge of my seat every episode my
buddy goes to [ __ ]
comes back from uh whatever
work and he goes how'd it go because he
knew it was gonna happen
i just didn't want him involved how was
your day
and i said it wasn't it didn't go too
good this is what happened
i know you want a line of coke he's like
sure so we started doing a couple of
lines
and also near on the door
and i looked the window it's it's
[ __ ] the dew with the people
and i go what do you want uh he's out
now
yeah he you know he i left him at his
house yeah with the fella in the room
with a dog i don't know what happened
this is four hours later
he knocks on my door he's like i need to
talk to you i go what do i do he goes
what do i do with him i go i don't know
it's your [ __ ] he goes that's my
[ __ ] mother's house
you know what happens if i get arrested
my mother says i don't know you should
have thought of that before he tried to
rob me
he goes i didn't rob me that's all that
was there was 200 i'm telling you right
now that's all that was there
he goes you don't understand i need 10
000 to get [ __ ] married
if i get that money she'll divorce the
guy and i get mad and i'll never forget
looking at him going
this poor [ __ ] bastard this is all
over some [ __ ]
this is all over for [ __ ] she's like i
need this [ __ ] money i told i'd have
the money tonight
she's going to the attorney tomorrow she
could file for divorce tomorrow
afternoon
and i could be [ __ ] her in three
months once a divorce is over i need
this [ __ ] money
and then he goes you got to do me a
[ __ ] favor i know these guys i got
two blocks of hash they're staying at a
hotel
get your gun let's go over and i go do
you not understand it's over
i go where's kent he goes he's in the
trunk of a car
he goes i'm going to take him down to
[ __ ] the bus station and put him on
the bus
i suggest you get going he goes you're
coming with me i ain't going nowhere
i ain't going to [ __ ] know and i
think if the truth was i pulled my piece
on
i think that i finally go dog get the
[ __ ] off my thing
don't ever [ __ ] come on this lot
again make believe you never [ __ ]
know me
i went back inside my girlfriend went
home she knew something was
going on [ __ ] that night i went
across the street for dinner i got the
trout almondine
it was the special like 6.95 a
potato
the guys in the truck and i'm like hold
on look up trout
almond i have never even heard of that
[ __ ] i want to know what's in it
colorado i want to know what to do
[Music]
man i'm international we got lake trout
in baltimore we don't
have no trout almost speaking of
baltimore jimmy's seafood
yeah the best the best the best seafood
out there no doubt
it's it's mainly almonds yeah see if i
can find the recipe that does sound good
man i've never had that trout with
almonds huh
there was a bar across the street and
that was disgusting
it was like trout almondine or a [ __ ]
skinny steak with aids it just
it says it's butter shallots lemons and
almonds that's
delicious and they give it to you
without the head
just the skin you just eat the skin
[ __ ] delicious you understand me
spray that up
spray it up the most criminals have
trout on monday for that
night there's a guy in the trunk right
now he's having trout i went back to the
house
i stopped at the liquor store i went
back to the house i knew i had a dilemma
i knew i had i knew that something was
not
gonna go right and i went home and i
proceeded to snort that coke
line by line and drink
and at some point i just passed out from
mental exhaustion and worrying myself to
death
even after that coke and everything it
must have been wiped out i was wiped out
i i knew that this was not gonna be good
somewhere along the line is gonna bite
me in the ass
and sure enough the next day i wake up
to
[Music]
and i look out the window like that you
know i could look out the window not
them knowing
and it was uh the kid who detailed cars
now at subaru
and he had a name i forget what his name
was which one the uh
not less to the molester he had like a
different name like [ __ ] uh
blazing brett hazen ah that was his
sound that was his name that was his
name
he was a detailer but he was blazing
because we used to give him coke
so he would wash like 18 cars in 10
minutes
blazing bread hazing i love brazen bud
hazen good white dude
solid solid family he just snorted coke
from seven that's from ding da dang dig
the dong yeah nine o'clock he'd be out
there that'd be
30 degrees he'd be washing cars with no
shirt on you know
oh my god 30 degrees october he's out
there no shirt on that's how coked up he
is
you don't even feel the weather he's out
there sprinkling water and [ __ ]
blazing bread haze and knocks on my door
i go brett what's going on he goes open
the door he goes man
i hate to be the brad bad news but at
work right now they got to play
surrounded with cops
they're looking for you today that
something happened
like are you serious because yeah
they're trying to get your address right
now
wayne means to stall them they're all
[ __ ] stalling them right now
but here's the weird thing
that the night before
the day i went to the dentist you know
that dude that gave me the 500 bucks
and we never talked i was standing
outside it had to be about
7 15 and the sun was setting
same guy you said you're a nosy
[ __ ] huh that one i just didn't
like him
he was older but i knew
he deserved respect i just at that age i
wasn't gonna give it to him
i thought he was a [ __ ] for what he
did trying to cut it on my deal
and at that in those days i used to take
that type of [ __ ] personally
don't hit me with that if it's your deal
for real then the guy would ask for
[ __ ] riot
okay you're not going to show up at the
end that was the kind of [ __ ] it was
like joke dealing stealing you know
it was one of the taboos of the business
and he was going to pull it on me
so i felt i didn't have to talk to him
but maybe a night or two before i did
that
kitty is crying i was standing outside
by myself and he came up to me
and he goes hey do you have a minute
and i'm about you know like somebody
asking if you have a minute when you
hate them
i go yeah what's up and he goes i don't
know if you know
this but before i came to work here
i was the entertainment director at a
casino in las vegas i booked everybody
have you ever considered doing stand-up
comedy this is the guy
i'm like are you [ __ ] serious that's
the advice you have for me
that i should become a stand-up comic
he's like you're a stand-up comic
and i was like thank you for that and i
didn't take it with a grain of [ __ ]
salt
and now i've been looking up my fat you
know his name comes in and out
like i should have wrote it down but i
didn't
uh that was the first time somebody was
like
so here's this guy that does not like me
and i'm not crazy about him comes up to
me one night and tells me
that i should be doing stand-up comics
you don't even
seem and he pushes you on the path he
pushes how about that man that's crazy
isn't that crazy so blind breaks
blazing brett hayes is on my and he goes
the cops gonna be
in about eight minutes get everything
you need
so that night i had finished the coke i
took the [ __ ] scale i had
i already knew anything coke related
i put in two bags and i walked in one
direction to walk the dog
and i dumped it behind the supermarket
and then i walked an extra half mile
coked up and walked up behind another
guy's personal
garbage i went home the house was clean
wiped down the table vacuumed sprayed
lysol
there was no residue of cocaine nothing
i knew the cops were gonna come it was
just a matter of when
sure enough he goes you gotta go thank
god i [ __ ]
showered like i [ __ ] showered got
dressed
and as i was walking up the corner the
cops are coming down my block with their
lights on
how many um two cop cars and one
detective car
they pulled up in my house they
approached slowly
you know they knocked you're watching
i'm watching this
they knocked the door where are you are
you hiding are you just
i'm across the street at the supermarket
behind the beam
and they can't see me i'm watching them
behind the get out from behind
me at the supermarket they didn't kick
my door open anything they just walked
around the premises
they couldn't walk on the one side
because the dog was back there
so that's i didn't want them to shoot my
dog or not like that so
i watched them all go to the front talk
and then two cop cars left and they left
a cop car outside to see if i would come
home
so i called the girl me and her on the
outside
you're not gonna believe this the cops
are looking for me
you gotta help me and she's like jesus
[ __ ] christ
where are you i go i'm in raushan not
rouse
king supers that's the supermarket chain
i go king supers on blah blah blah
and she goes okay give me about 25
minutes i'll meet you in the front
lay low so i'm watching these [ __ ]
cops and i reach
and i'm like where's my weed
in those days i was getting weed sent
out buddha thai wheat chocolate
taiwanese
yeah and how about it out of new york
like [ __ ] this i walked all the way
around
i jumped the fence behind my house and i
went in my back door the cops never even
knew it
come on i went in i got my weed my pipe
there and the guy's still sitting out
there out there drinking talking about
[ __ ] how they're arresting
jesse james and all these [ __ ] and
here's a [ __ ] 25 year old
i was 24. sneaking behind the house
boom my girlfriend picked me up and she
goes we're lucky because my parents went
away for the week
so we could just go up there you have no
excuses like it all worked out
so i went up there on a wednesday
and then thursday i was kind of bored
and i would go down the hill and call my
buddy
at his job and ask him what's going on
he would tell me the cops are snooping
around
they're looking for you there's an
article in the paper about it that
there's one guy they're looking for
still so it's like [ __ ]
they did pinch the other dude they got
him yeah how they arrested him was he
was driving without his headlights on
that's always something stupid i pulled
over and they heard the guy in the trunk
kicking and [ __ ] moaning wait
that he didn't get pulled he got pulled
over with the dude in the trunk not just
some [ __ ] like
come on yes my story is god written
only steve [ __ ] martin could write
the story
i was involved with a complete
nincompoop he was an
idiot he was driving his headlights off
with a guy in the trunk
when he the cop asked him for license
registration
all you heard was
it was like good fellas let me out yeah
so here's the funny story
the victim never mentioned my name
the victim said ratted tidwell
out tidwell ratted me up
so it's thursday night
i'm bored to pieces jim wheeler kept
telling me to watch above the law with
steve sagal had just come out
tremendous stephen cigar movie you've
never seen steven seagal that is a good
yeah he's a joke today but his first
three movies were tremendous that one
being tremendous
i rented that another movie that was hot
at the time that i'd never watched
before called lethal weapon
lethal weapon was hot off the presses
so i went to get weed and i went to the
video store
and it was across the street from the
kmart where i used to rob
years later i used to rob receipts
there were three phone booths
i went to the phone booth and i because
my friend said the detective left his
car do you want his number and i go yeah
i write it
so i called the detective up and it's
like who is this joey diaz hold on
they will put me on hold to trace the
call and i would hang up
then i called back and i'd hang up and i
called back and i hang up i called back
and i hang up
and finally they're like hey i'm
detective whatever and i'm like
what's going on he goes listen i need to
talk to you it's not
important it's just a few questions
and let's just get this figured out and
i go all right
and he goes where are you and i look up
and i'm about to say k-mart but this is
an
albertsons about 400 yards from me i go
i'm at albertsons
and he goes wait for us we'll be right
there i hung up the phone
and not three minutes later i see a cop
car
dashing into albertson's where this
light's on i s i'm seeing all these cops
come in there
and i'm seeing them get out of their
cars and run into albans with that gun
i'm in my car rolling the joint watch
them
you're not nervous at all i'm like i'm
dead what are they gonna do across the
street
they didn't trace the call i didn't give
them enough time i was on the clock jack
i know exactly when that phone clicks
and you're using all three of them yeah
i'm using all three of them i was a bad
[ __ ]
oh yeah so when i saw all those cops i
was like
this ain't a game they're gonna [ __ ]
get me
so i went home to my girlfriend i told
her what i had seen
and we agreed on turning myself in there
was only a problem
i had a big [ __ ] problem on that
night miami vice don
johnson was marrying sheena easton
i'm a huge miami vice fan i'm waiting
for this [ __ ] wedding i'm getting a
grammar blow i'm getting chinese food
i'm [ __ ] my girlfriend and i'm gonna
celebrate the wedding
my man crockett is gonna marry sheila
[ __ ] easton on national tv
i got a [ __ ] dilemma here lee you
think you're [ __ ]
this is real retardation
i was like i got the cops looking for me
and i'm worried about a wedding
not even a real one a real yeah that's
something everybody's watching every
wedding
that's to let people know you know like
when you guys on patreon
i'm 24. i don't know what to do let me
tell you what i was doing at 24.
i was going to imaginary cocaine
weddings
i'm the guy you want to listen to i've
done everything stupid in the world
i didn't even tell you what happened or
not after i ate that pill
i found the pill on the floor right here
yeah no it wasn't a joke
this was a [ __ ] boogaloo pill and i
ate it had a rough night that night
i fell asleep on my wife twice like
talking to her
she's like where are you going i got it
she goes you fell asleep talk to me
anyway
i uh i know i'm in trouble but i got
this wedding
like he's really gone i think he'd be
like the best man in your head or
something i got this wedding together
i'm gonna watch elvis's alligators is he
there
so i said [ __ ] this i'll turn myself in
by nine
i'll talk to him i'll talk about this
you mean nine a.m on saturday morning so
you can watch friday night because if i
remember correctly wasn't my everybody's
friday night at
10 p.m was it nine nine ten yeah yeah i
go if i go in that nine and talk to them
i'll be home by eight
so i go down there i give my wife my
ex-wife my girlfriend at the time
i give it like 40 bucks like oh remember
pick up egg food young
pork fried rice i should be up there by
eight i'll call you
you can pick me up i'll take the bus up
or whatever you know and i remember
going up the police station
going white detective colar's office
you're like it's up there and i remember
going up there and there was nobody
standing outside there was a buzzer
i'm like and they're like who is i'm
like joey d
is annoying hold on okay come in
and when i open the door every cop in
that office
is holding a gun really get on your
knees get on your knees
and austin they come out mr diaz you're
arrested for kidnapping one kidnapping
two aggravated robbery
put your hands behind your neck but is
there somebody you want to talk to you
know they read me there right he's
freaking out at that point
no i'm like what are you arresting me
for i didn't do nothing
i [ __ ] helped you guys i took a
[ __ ] drug deal off the streets
i'm a superhero why are you treating a
superhero like this
superheroes lives matters
how quickly do you think about the
wedding though like how quick are you
do you realize like oh [ __ ] i go see
this wedding
no there's no dvr about the [ __ ]
dropping on these
but we still had the vcr yeah the vcr
[Laughter]
so oh my god i turned myself in at 9
15. and they're like do you want to talk
to us and i'm like absolutely i'll tell
you whatever you want to hear
and they asked me what i knew and i gave
them like a half-assed version
and then i would just tell them stories
they would tell you i got my driver's
license test in colorado and they're
like what
and they're like what does this have to
do with i'll never forget tell them that
story and they're like
that's great okay can we get back to
this so
when did you see ken vellante i didn't
see ken vella
well you didn't see him at the house no
i saw him before he
said he was going to arizona on a trip i
was just
and after a while listen we didn't want
to talk to you though
you got bail that's it and they put me
in boulder county jail
they gave me a pack of cigarettes in
those days they give you cigarettes
and they put me like in this [ __ ]
thing that was paradise
i keep my own clothes my girlfriend
brought me clothes the next day
so you missed the wedding i missed a
wedding no
by the time i got to my room that was
everybody was catching the wedding was
it was on in jail
no you saw it in jail last half hour i
was happy as [ __ ] but no chinese food
no chinese food you can't always get
everything
and that night wow holy [ __ ] oh my god
and then
they made a big deal of it by the time
by the time i
got sentenced by the time i got charged
they had accused me of kidnapping the
cuban kid
had tied me into that oh okay so they
tied every drug rip
to me now they were like we're looking
at them for other possible
situations the murder of our bird or
something i'm like what
and they're like disappearance of this
and i'm like nah nah nah whoa
nelly whoa nelly i tried to take drugs
off the street
that was my only crime here but they
wouldn't go for it so i think i spent
thanksgiving in jail
damn i went from november 9th november
20th
i spent thanksgiving in jail and then my
ex-wife
girlfriend at the time went to her
father and told him the truth
told them i made a mistake you know the
guy always knew i worked i hustled
i used to go up there on saturdays and
help him cut trees and [ __ ]
so she goes make an appointment for him
to come see me and he came to see me and
he asked me what happened
and he told me not to leave out of
detail
and i told him the truth and he said he
bailed me out
and three days later i was bailed out to
his supervision do you remember what
bail
was it's probably bail was originally 50
g's
once he got involved they loaded to
three g's cash
it's only 10 anyway right so they
dropped it from five to three just
straight up okay so they dropped it two
thousand yeah that's four drops of two
thousand
and i had to be signed up to his custody
to stay with him
so i pretty much lived with my
girlfriend's family for like the first
month like that moment of
december they were like it's best that
you stay here with us for the holidays
and
i was a [ __ ] mess like i was a mess
i was trying to get attorneys from all
over the country and
like i was thinking like i was like a
mobster and [ __ ] like that and
they're like we want 30 thousand just to
get on the plane i'm like what
so that's uh
a different story in itself like that's
me getting out of that
i think i stayed in there for 16 or 17
days
it was something weird because it [ __ ]
with me
i came out and jim wheeler was the
manager at a subaru store
he gave me a job for about a month and a
half i only sold one car
damn i couldn't even sell cars i was so
unfocused
was that 16 or 17 days as long as you've
been in jail to that point
yeah the whole situation that mess with
me
because then it got cleared up to me
that bella never ran in
it was ted well but let me tell you what
happened tidwell got arrested in
jefferson county
so when they brought tidwell in
a clerk did a background check on him
and realized he had a warrant for 19
dollars
he paid the nineteen dollars and they
let him out by mistake
right so tidwell was wanted
before i saw he made himself look or
worse
then he eventually turned himself in i
got out of jail
i [ __ ] up the job with the thing
it was a funny story because
it's gonna sound bad but let's say it
anyway that doesn't sound great so far
at first i had to get
an attorney but since he got arrested
the night before
he got a public attorney okay
when you got represented by a public
attorney that means i can't get
represented by a public attorney
because it's conflict of interest so
they have to get me a court appointed
attorney
well the court appointed attorney they
got me his name was sonny flowers
and what his claims
sunny flowers another big black dude six
foot
six what do you want to do
the only problem was he was scared of
black people he was black but he was
scared of black
six six he's scared he was raised like
very high my name is sonny
flowers but his claim to fame was his
grandmother was the first
african-american woman
to get a law degree from the university
of colorado man that's huge
all right son yeah but he wasn't doing
nothing to me so what good was he was
selling me out
you know what i'm saying i thought cuban
lives matter what
now cuban what the [ __ ] what happened
so i played him like a fiddle throughout
january
and february because i knew i couldn't
go into the courtroom with him i knew he
wasn't confident
i had been around courts enough
to know he was incompetent
so i played him
i played him until he brought me the
first offer
the first offer was nine years
and i got a plea to kidnap him too [ __ ]
you
hold on you're you're off mike i can't i
really can you hear him all right
i think we should be able to know yeah
there you go so wait say i'm sorry i
might
first i wanted there to see something
one day and he goes oh by the way i got
an offer for you
it made you a great deal this is sonny's
telling you what they already came back
they're not going to do nothing better
because it's nine years and kidnapping
too
oh yeah i'm like what prison
i go you saw me i duck you gotta fight
to me
there's no fingerprints on the machine
gun there's none of this there's none
out what puts me there
what the [ __ ] is going on here so i got
into kind of an argument with him
and he's like well if you feel that way
but this is what i wanted
because i wanted to kill time
the more time i killed the more chance i
had the victim would disappear
without me killing him he's a loose
cannon without me
killing him he listen he couldn't
testify against me because
and today we're dear friends like we
just spoke about 11 days ago
but at that time he couldn't testify
because they were going to bring up the
story about him robbing the pharmacy
he had no credibility you know what i'm
saying they took you to the hospital
they want to stitch you up and what do
you do
you break into the [ __ ] pharmacy and
steal coke and run out of there
and he had done a couple of a lot of
things so they didn't really have
that strong of a [ __ ] case but i
couldn't take the chance
so i had to set a date
to fire my attorney in front of the
judge
so i knew that would kill three more
months you see i'm saying
to get me a qualified attorney
to attack this a different way i knew
how this was going to be attacked
i had to come up with the attack myself
i was gonna be attacked
but i needed somebody to hatch the plan
with me and he was way better than me
until today i love him his name is phil
dubois he's the one
he's out of colorado springs he was a
genius
he took me on as a client when i fired
sunny flowers
and i went to court that day the judge
said to me mr diaz before you leave
go to my court clerk and ask her
what uh
to give you a list of attorneys i had
already
picked my attorney but i went back there
were there anywhere to play the game
when i went back there there were three
cops back there
there was jimmy cola and there was two
dea agents
and they were like hey how you doing you
remember us and they threw an envelope
down
and they're like what happened you don't
go back to aspen no more aspen's no
no good and i'm like what are you
talking about and they're like you were
living up in aspen you were having a
great time
selling blow flying it back selling guns
we just miss you by getting you this
much but we could still bring those
charges back
we have proof i don't know what you're
talking about and they started putting
pictures out
of me at the airport they've been
following you that long
oh yeah how many years they had been
following me
i got hot to them like september of 86
to november of 86. and they were just
watching
because a girl in aspen an accountant
was a city accountant she got caught
robbing
so when they pressed charges she said
what if i give you drug dealers
they asked what were you spending the
money on drugs so they made her and her
husband
go out and buy drugs from different drug
deals and when they then they caught on
to me with the guns
and then like there was other drug
people that ratted me out that they had
you know they bought the cops off
i mean there was some big-time [ __ ]
hitters up there at the time
so they came to me they showed me all
those pictures
and they said we could cut your deal we
know you're involved
we could press charges listen if you
could have pressed charges you would
have pressed charges already
we will be having this [ __ ]
conversation so
let me think about it and get back to
you and it was so funny because cola
gave me his number and i would call
caller up and give him lee's plate
and then they'd really be baffled
because they're like how's he doing it
please not a coke deal he doesn't go out
at night how does he sell it does he
email it
you know people i was just playing with
them
i would see a license plate and no guy
in it and i just write it down
i go you see this guy right there in
that license plate i saw him
selling right i saw him selling drugs
little girls the other day
i'm saying watch him he's got lollipops
i would just give him fake information
but it was so weird how i had to flip my
life
in those couple of months like i really
i joined the master swimming program
i tried to get into the university of
colorado i got my ged
i did so and it's all par is this all
part
of building a case for yourself
so that when you finally get the report
for this you can say
right this was part of me trying to be
joey diaz trying to
play a routine i never forget i signed
up for a
voluntary drug test wait right
my attorney goes i think it's a good
idea i don't know about that you signed
up for voluntary drug tests
i don't mean to be rude to the past one
i remember the third time they were like
why do you come here
they're like the last dose you gave us
that's the highest
sea level we ever saw in our lives
what did you [ __ ] bathe in it so that
became my attorney got that ripped up
let's rip that piece of paper because it
helps you if you go to court and say
you've been clean
but if they don't know it ain't going to
hurt you either so what just don't bring
it up
you know i'm saying so i i did
everything i had to do i went to
counseling i went to the aaa meetings
i did everything i had to do except stay
clean
i ended up moving in with a guy that saw
coke like it didn't end
and he would hide in his jacket pocket
and leave and it was like
do what you need and it was crazy
it was every [ __ ] night but i'd be up
at six to swim
i had to be at the pool at ten to six
monday wednesdays and fridays because
a part of me thought i would get away
with the
with the court date like i would go to
court
and get community corrections but the
other part of me was like
who the [ __ ] am i kidding i'm going to
jail i'm accepting this because
this is i'm not going to jail for this
i'm going to jail for everything else i
need yeah
once i get this out of the way i could
move forward
it finally caught up to you but this is
i'm going to jail for everything else so
not hearing let's stop being a [ __ ]
jerk off you know
how much anxiety did you have in that
period when you were waiting
between you and i guys
i wasn't scared at all what because
even doing all that coke you weren't
getting paranoid about because we're not
talking about jail now we're talking
about
prison right prison are we not we're
talking about prison that's a
big difference number one i had spoken
to my
my father-in-law future hooked me up
with one of his clients
god rest his soul his name was ed crash
quebec he should not have been a car
salesman
and crash kabash became a car salesman
lately
that crash came out ed crash kabash
was a [ __ ] computer wizard that
devised some program on the computer in
1985
and somebody gave him a huge
one of those dudes huh so he was married
with a kid and he discovered a drug
called cocaine
and he lost his mind
okay and my father-in-law insured him
and my father-in-law would come to
dinner every week and every week he'd
tell us about a story about a client he
has
that keeps crashing cars oh no
and it was hysterical it was in the
paper
had crash cabash owned the liquor store
he was selling coke out of their
million-dollar year operation my
father-in-law was embarrassed
he knew him from the church so when ed
came out of jail
my father-in-law made me go talk to ed
crash come back
and that cash cabazz goes get 500
together
i'll send it to one of the guards so
when you get to where you're going
the toughest place it'll be easy for you
at least they'll take k so i knew that
if when i was in county jails i wouldn't
have prom
it's once i went to diagnostic is where
your problems start
but he goes i'll make it that it's easy
as [ __ ] for you
ed krashka bash is very interesting
because the story goes
he crashed 16 cars 16. then his record
was two
the same week two testa roses ah
i mean the dog he was making speaking of
miami vice listen to me he was making so
much money
he got sick and tired of going to a
liquor store so he bought his own liquor
store
and he was selling coke out of the
liquor store in kilos
and he was just sitting there all day
mixing drinks
and getting [ __ ] up so i went to him
he prepped me so one part of me
thought uh joey diaz got this licked
well i'm not gonna lie to you
the other part of me was preparing to go
and i did everything i went i signed up
for courses
i got accepted into the ceo p work study
program at the university of colorado
we presented our [ __ ] uh
presentation to the [ __ ] so let me
ask you a question how long from the
time
your bailed out till the time you
finally go back to court like what
free time do you have how many is it
months is it a few weeks like how much
time do you have
well done let's say december 8th
and now this creeps into 88 i'm hoping
me and my cocaine mind
i'm hoping to keep this
on the books to 89. oh okay
so you'd be out and about no that's just
so stressful i was hoping to stretch it
out
so the victim could change the story
right the victim could [ __ ] it up
the victim was starting to renege
already he didn't want to come back to
testify
but they still had the other guy that
was going to testify against me
so i was going to lose so my attorney
came up with a great idea
he goes why don't we hire private
investigators and cost you an extra
three grand
you're already fighting for your life
but this guy will dig into your life and
whatever he finds you can present it to
the judge
and well at least we know what they're
gonna find
and he put together this presentation
man
and he cut them off at the chase you saw
him you hit them first so they didn't
have it oh yeah
[ __ ] he calls me one day and he goes
what do you think
of this deal if i can make it
and i go hit me and he goes how about
90 days work release
and six years community corrections what
does that mean yeah what is community
correct
work release means you're sleeping there
at night
go to a prison a county jail
sleep in there at night be released till
six
get pissed tested three times a week oh
yeah i forgot about the piss test and
then
and then you're there these days i go to
a
six months treatment center at bctc the
halfway house
which remember
yes this is why life is a [ __ ]
so that isn't safe he's pushing for 6
90 community corrections we're looking
at november
december by that time bella would be too
[ __ ] up
he won't show up ted will kill himself i
was trying to get to 10 well
you know i was trying to do everything
my [ __ ] lawyer calls me in july and
he goes listen
the [ __ ] judge switched his dock and
he moved your case to august
15th he goes i'm going in front of
community correction see i was supposed
to get
a sentence in december and then
with the result of community corrections
community corrections meeting was august
12th
so they switched my so i'm like what
does that mean
he goes he goes that means that
afternoon you'll know whether you're
going to prison or not
okay so i kept living my life i was
living it mike tyson knocked out the
brother without the tooth
in atlantic city in 16 16 seconds
i'm snorting coke i got my girlfriend
and all of a sudden i'm doing something
i had forgotten all about it
on a friday the phone rings it's my
journey because you're still sitting up
standing down like i'm standing up
because you better sit down for this one
because community corrections turned you
down
i go what does that mean he goes well
that means that [ __ ]
i could probably get you into work
release
but it ain't gonna be for no [ __ ]
three months it's gonna be for like a
year
but still just work release for a year
but what i did was
i paid the best attorney and i took a
session with him for like an
hour i went and i paid him his fee
and i had him break it down he was a
spanish dude he was in charge of the law
school he was the dean of the law school
that's why i was getting to a law school
because if you said you were spanish
they'd beg
you could have lefts yourself
they just needed a latino on the roster
to get their funding
no they needed a latino to get
get that to get that government grant
money and [ __ ]
you got to show up with four [ __ ]
spanish people
they don't care if they're bouncing the
ball or not you know what i'm saying
they come in with one of those paddles
with a ball
sit down we're gonna give you 8 000 a
semester we'll give you a call a car
yeah we'll give you a car too don't
worry about nothing
so i got involved with that so i i met
with him
and he told me to my face he's like
you're a nice guy
i'm looking at your police record i'm
looking at your probation report
you're never gonna get in trouble again
but
there was a machine gun involved
and he goes that means there's a
potential for violence which
means that somebody could have been shot
with the cuban kid and the kid jumping
off the balcony and breaking his [ __ ]
legs
they're gonna [ __ ] come after you so
just be prepared to do time so i knew it
i really knew it so that i got off the
phone with the attorney
i started snorting my brains out friday
i took my girlfriend ate her ass up the
[ __ ]
i think i tasted the heart at my heart i
licked the heart
oh i must have [ __ ] 18 times that poor
girl
and that that sunday that monday morning
i walked into court with this attitude
that
you know what the judge is going to give
me a chance to talk
i'm going to tell them about what i've
done the last six months
i got into college i got my ged just
give me a breathe
let me do work release bro when that
judge called and i had
i had my friends flying from jersey
they're flying in
that's nice i had good friends man they
flew in from jersey
george who went from jersey
and they called my name i thought it was
going to be like this beautiful thing
and he goes jose diaz do you have any
words
and i went to talk and i just froze up
i'm like and he goes
uh everybody stand so you never got
you've never said anything because your
sentence is
four to six years department of
corrections
with a 90-day uh appeals whatever thank
you for coming
and i looked at the judge because my
buddies had an ounce and a half a coke
i look at the attorney and i go talk to
him see if we can stay out till
wednesday
my buddy brought a rock direct from
[ __ ] bolivia
and my attorney goes excuse me it says
joey signed up into college
and he have two days to turn himself in
the guy goes no
he's a surrender right now my [ __ ]
girlfriend was heartbroken her parents
were there her family was there
you know my friends were there to hug
them all yeah because you're walking
you're walk you're not leaving no i walk
to the back
[ __ ] uh
can i let me ask you this kidnapping one
and two what are the
what is that what it was a one and what
it makes it a one and a two is what i'm
trying to get
and and kidnapping is such a i know it's
because you physically moved a person
against their will but why do they still
use
kid i don't know they just sound
terrible
it sounds terrible uh the first degree
is
if they're harmed or a threat of
physical harm and second degree is no
none of that threat of physical harm and
that was the machine gun
that's it that's makes it the one so you
right there you they let you hug
everybody goodbye and you go right into
custody
what day is this it's a monday morning
august 15
1988 88 i sit in the cell
it's getting hot in there are you by
yourself i'm by myself
it's a nice cell it's got a little it's
clean
you know and as you know right now you
have 90 days to appeal but you're doing
four to six no i'm not
it's called consideration motion oh okay
because the
uh the reason why i went to prison was
because i wasn't claiming
responsibility the judge said if you
would have came in here claiming
responsibility
i would have given you a smack on the
wrist but the whole
the whole [ __ ] year all you keep
talking about
is you didn't know nothing you don't
know nothing you didn't know nothing
you knew all you got to do is say it
when you're ready to say it come back in
front of my court
so i had to think a lot about a lot of
things and not stay with me forever
that's why when i bomb it's not the
audience fault
it's your fault why are you blaming the
[ __ ] audience for that's what a dummy
does
it's always your fault it's always your
fault so it really
taught me that so i go in this little
cell the size of this office
i take my 800 jacket suit off it did me
no good
[Laughter]
i just spit on the [ __ ] thing you
piece of [ __ ] unlucky suit
i thought i was impressed to judge with
an armani did nothing for me
but when i hit the suit
ryan i can't write this i hit the suit
and i'm like
what's in the pocket it's just a
handkerchief
and i got to take the handkerchief out
and there's a [ __ ] coke better along
and i'm in the cell going jesus lives
jesus i crush the [ __ ] coke
i turn around and i know they got a
camera in there i roll up like a dollar
and i make believe i'm pissing
and i snort the whole [ __ ] package
follow away flush the [ __ ] package
and i sit down now i'm in that cell
[ __ ] up
i'm like i got some water yeah and then
came back with a big glass of water and
i just stabbed there
and then i passed out after that yeah
because it had been that's it that's got
to be so
because i had the whole yeah it finally
got wet yeah the coke took me higher
and i just went down not just six months
your whole life
up to this point has been has been
skirting around it
avoiding it every way possible and
finally
that got you so this cop comes over he
gets me because i'm gonna bring it to
yourself give you some clothes
change we gotta search you
he searches me it's about
8 30 at night they bring me into the
cell
and who's sitting there playing cards
a guy with two broken legs they gotta
jump no
i can't look at the broken legs is that
you that jumped out the window
we'll end it right there in county jail
boulder colorado december no
uh i turned myself in yes august
15. so we're 88 and then we're gonna
pick up on the honeydew
september 1988 in jail sitting next to
the dude with two broken legs
i love you john yeah
that was the most interesting
two weeks of my life because
i got to hear everything that i had
confirmed
it was because remember at first they
put me in federal holding
kidnapping is a federal offense and then
after 72 hours
they put me back into a regular county
jail
so in federal jail i got to talk to
these people and it was
mind-boggling those first 72 hours
were mind-boggling because there were
stories about
these were high level characters
and how they got infiltrated and it was
one of the most
brilliant three days of my life
this one guy got busted his wife went
and got it made the maid was a fed
[ __ ] fed bought two kilos of coke
from her now they were both in jail
just tremendous stories tremendous
stories about another guy that told me
[ __ ] uh a guy that he would shoot
coke with
shoot coke would shoot coke with shot
coke with him for
six seven months then one night the guy
goes i want to buy a kilo
the next day he gets arrested he can't
figure out
they hid the witness to hit the witness
the day of
testifying the cop was the guy that was
shooting the coke
they sent them to a rehab they do
plastic surgery on their arm
and you could sit there all you want and
say they interrupted you
but that was like the the [ __ ] those two
weeks
those three days in federal holding were
brilliant i still remember going
downstairs
to get sent like to go to court they
made me go to court even though i didn't
have to go to court
and they handcuffed me like to a crazy
guy oh
i kept getting up and going i didn't
[ __ ] do it [ __ ] yourself
and they're all looking at me and
they're throwing punches and i got a
duck up and [ __ ]
you have no idea my friend
well thank you it has been an honor to
guest host the church thank you for
letting me do this for real this has
been [ __ ] awesome
you know i love you um follow me on ryan
sickler on social media ryancicle.com
make sure you're following along
on is that am i looking at the right
camera the honeydew we're doing
joey's entire life story we'll get one
more in before you head back to jersey
and then we're going to zoom them
whenever the [ __ ] you want to do them
from the luxury of your own home
cover free and safe i love you brother
thank you
and i'm going to miss you dearly yeah
one of the guys that
really came through in my life later on
i was in a bad spot for a few years
but whenever i saw you you made me feel
like we weren't in hollywood we were in
baltimore you gave me a piece of the
east coast
that obviously is what i was needing so
same dude thank you for your friendship
thank you for your loyalty thank you for
your career i'm so proud that you're
doing so well you got your thank you
cast and uh anything i could do for you
in jersey
i'll do i love you dude i and look i
want to say this
you know when i was going through
splitting with my daughter's mom and
everything and i know you like that i
say
daughter's mother and not baby mama when
i was splitting with her
you were checking in on me all the time
i tell everybody no he
called me he didn't text me he called
and called
and called so i love you for it thank
you brother i love you thank you very
much
all right i want to thank ryan sickler
for coming on the show
we always got some type of [ __ ] story
to tell this [ __ ]
but anyway listen the church is brought
to you by
draftkings like i told you earlier this
saturday is ufc
252 and draftkings has a knockout of a
deal for you
better buck to win 252
draftkings sportsbook is legit that
based right here in the us
your money is secure deposit and take
money out at any time
at your convenience and if and if
draftking sportsbook isn't available
where you live yet
don't forget about the draftkings
fantasy app i know you've seen a
commercial on tv
they're offering a shot at one million
bucks every day
this week that's five [ __ ] mill
they're giving away this week who do you
hang out with that gives away five mil
nobody get on the action right now
download draftking sportsbook now
and use code church plus for a limited
time
just for the church family all new users
get a sign up bonus of a thousand
dollars that's right
did you hear what i'm saying a thousand
dollars [ __ ] trump with his [ __ ]
uh stimulus check there's a thousand
dollars for you to [ __ ] play all
right
only at draftkings sportsbook and here's
the part the lawyers make me say
must be 21 old in new jersey indiana and
pennsylvania only
deposit bonus requires a 25 times play
through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details and if you got a
gaming problem
there's help all right call 1-800
gambler or if you're in indiana call
1-809
with it and tell them uncle joey sent
you but first
download the draftking sports book app
and use code church
i want to thank ryan i want to thank lee
most importantly
i want to thank you [ __ ] for
being a part of these last few episodes
have a great day stay black kick this
[ __ ] mule lee
[Music]
you